I mean hey man bro I'm singing a song in
the beginning Dharam you don't interrupt
me until I [ __ ] introduce you man we
got kalila my beautiful kalila my
beautiful [ __ ] island queen from the
mud rivers of coure the Philippines
we've got the Philippine river we got
two dimensional face
Gilbert can't see me yeah he goes to the
side he disappears it's the lines Brown
line be a great character on Charlie
Brown we got we have right here Richard
Ramirez he's back night suckers back
Night Stalker actually don't like how
he's in the clouds night and we got
accomplished a girl in there just like
George key mole that's how you pronounce
it and we got a very special cuz we've
had them before this I think this is the
first time we've you know we've used a
saw a couple of times but this is his
fat land oh there's a new movie called
already crossed at Star Wars and he is
fat Lando and Cloud City
you're fat Yoda [ __ ] oh yeah get on
Luke Skywalker back
[Applause]
yeah so we got Eric Griffin back and
he's on a new television program called
I'm dying up here and it's on Showtime
and my special comes out July 7th we're
gonna do that [ __ ] dude I'm sorry
intern this is structure River over here
oh yeah yeah and when I get my beard to
transplant which is what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna use I'm gonna use your knuckle
hairs I mean what the [ __ ]
you haven't evolved fully no this is
like right before the a werewolf movie
the guy goes you know or wax it
I've tried then it turns into your
butthole yeah yeah yeah oh my god that's
so weird just noticed that that's really
bad because you're such a big guy that
there's just so much to look at here we
go so I just slowly noticed by the per
capita your way fatter proportionately
okay okay see this is the fun of me for
my dog this is a 1950s dog yeah a water
hose is gonna come out next